pour les candidats organiser une
campagne présidentielle ça coûte cher
très cher l'argent reste le nerf de la
guerre mise en scène bien consciente
coller des affiches voyager louer des
salles de meeting sa demande de l'argent
aujourd'hui les budgets des campagnes
électorales sont réglementés par l'état
mais avant 1988 ce n'était pas le cas
pas de contrôle rien alors cette année
là une loi est votée pour plafonner ces
budgets ça va donner en quelque sorte
une règle du jeu c'est à dire que
jusqu'à présent c'était un système
sauvage in organisé et que maintenant on
saura ce qui est licite et ce qui est
illicite à l'époque c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui doit vérifier ses
budgets
1995 pour la campagne présidentielle
aucun des candidats n'a dépassé les
plafonds pour les deux tours jacques
chirac avec le rpr ont dépensé près de
120 millions de francs
quand d'autres candidats ont dépensé
beaucoup moins comme dominique voynet
avec les verts
7,2 166 millions pour le premier tour
s'est pas non plus dans notre culture de
faire des campagnes électorales avec
d'énormes dépenses c'est à dire que
notre candidate d'un s'est déplacé plus
souvent en seconde classe qu'en première
classe pour tenir les comptes et rentrer
dans les clous une personne veille au
grain c'est le mandataire financier
chaque partie doit en choisir un c'est
la loi il reçoit les dons paye les
factures contrôler les dépenses à
l'image de jean jacques jégou mandataire
financier de françois bayrou en 2012 il
faut toujours être
un petit nombre mais efficace chacun
doit savoir ce qu'il a à faire et moi là
dedans je surveille
le mandataire financier surveille car si
le candidat respecte le plafond l'état
plus rembourser une partie de son budget
explications avec la présidentielle de
2017 au premier tour le seuil était de
16 851 millions d'euros pour le second
tour les candidats pouvaient avoir 5,7
millions en plus le plafond était donc
de 22 500 9 millions d'euros pour les
finalistes si le candidat fait moins de
5 % au premier tour alors l'état lui
rembourse au maximum 800 mille 423 euros
soit 4,75 % du plafond des dépenses du
premier tour s'il était plus de 5% il
est remboursé à 47 8 5% de ce plafond
soit un peu plus de 8 millions d'euros
alors certains candidats notamment les
plus petits surveillent leur budget j'ai
fait comme beaucoup des cornes et c'est
ce qui me paraît ce soit je ne vais pas
changer de garde-robe chemin je débats
van tol ça coûte pas très cher et gare à
ceux qui ne respectent pas ces plafonds
en 2012 nicolas sarkozy avait dépassé le
seuil résultat il n'avait pas été
remboursés en 2022 les plafonds restent
les mêmes qu'en 2010 est aujourd'hui les
budgets des candidats ne sont plus
contrôlés par le conseil constitutionnel
depuis 2006 c'est la commission
nationale des comptes de campagne et des
financements politiques qui s'en charge
[Musique]